SPEAKER: I'm pleased to
introduce Leonard Mlodinow
today.
He's a theoretical
physicist who is
good at making complex
scientific topics
interesting and
easy to understand.
He has five "New York
Times" bestsellers,
including "Subliminal
and the Grand Design,"
which he wrote together
with Stephen Hawking.
Among other TV shows, he
wrote for "Star Trek: The Next
Generation."
He's had numerous contributions
to various publications,
including "The New York
Times," "The Wall Street
Journal," "Scientific
American," as well as
appearances on a range of
TV shows from "Morning Joe"
to "Through the Wormhole."
Please join me in giving
him a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD MLODINOW: Thanks for
taking your time to come here,
because I had a little tour.
And I know you
could be at the gym,
you could be having
sushi with everybody,
you could be out walking
around the nice campus.
So wow.
This better be good, David.
It all depends on the moderator,
so if he's good, it'll be good.
SPEAKER: No pressure.
So your book is about
elastic thinking.
What do you mean by
elastic thinking?
LEONARD MLODINOW:
Well, I distinguish
between two different types
of thinking-- analytical,
or logical thinking,
which computers are really
good at, which you can
use to execute algorithms,
and it's very valued in society.
The SAT tests for it.
The employers, your
employers-- maybe not
Google because they know better,
but your employers generally
just look for that.
And then there is
elastic thinking, which
is more of a bottom-up process.
It's where ideas come from.
It's not how you
follow rules but it's
how you come up with
rules, how you get ideas.
Imagination, creativity, how you
integrate different knowledge
from different areas,
make new associations.
And so we need both
in most of what we do.
And my book is about
how elastic thinking
arises in your brain and
the psychology of it,
how you nurture it.
And so you can use your
rational, logical thinking
to figure out the best way to
drive to the grocery store.
But it's the elastic
thinking that
got someone to invent a car.
So that's how I describe it.
SPEAKER: Also in addition
to elastic thinking
and analytical
thinking, you talk
about autopilot and how some of
our lives we do on autopilot.
Can you give some
examples of this?
LEONARD MLODINOW: Yeah.
And I say it's not thinking.
It's just a matter
of definition.
But when I looked in
various dictionaries
and neuroscience
books, this kind
of information processing
that the brain does
did not seem to be
qualified as thinking.
And it's really a very
simple rule-based algorithm,
where there's a trigger
in your environment
that causes you to
do something and then
you execute that without even
processing it very deeply,
having any novelty or any kind
of flexibility in your brain.
One example is when you
drive to work on autopilot.
Your body and your mind
are just following the path
that you follow every day.
With me sometimes, if
I'm going somewhere,
I'll be driving somewhere
that was near Caltech,
I would start on
my way to Caltech
and pretty soon I realize,
I'm in Caltech, but that's
not where I was
going, because I'm
on autopilot and these
triggers, this stop sign
means turn left, that red
light means turn right.
And then I'm at the wrong place.
And it's been shown,
though, by psychologists
that these kinds of automatic
scripts or fixed action
patterns, as
psychologists call them,
aren't just for trivial
things like driving to work.
We actually engage in a lot of
our social and interpersonal
reactions that way.
For instance, people with
their significant other
or their spouse, sometimes
one says something
which triggers the other,
and pretty soon you're
on the same kind of
an argument pathway
that you have done
way too many times
and you know you don't want
to do but you keep doing it.
One other less emotional
example was a very famous study
done by Helen Langer, who is
one of my hero psychologists
at Harvard.
She stationed someone
near a Xerox machine.
And when someone came
up to use the copier,
this confederate would
walk up to the machine
and say one of three
different things.
So one thing that some of
them said was, excuse me,
can I get in front of you?
I have to Xerox five
pages, and I'm in a hurry.
Another way to say
it was, excuse me,
can I get in front of you
and use the Xerox machine?
And then she compared the
compliance rates of the two.
And people who gave the reason
that they're in a hurry,
they got 95% of people who
allowed them to do that.
And the people who didn't
give a reason, it was 60%.
Pretty agreeable, but
it was a big difference.
And then she had it
done another way.
The person would
walk up to the--
well, what she was asking
was, are these people
taking into account this reason
that this person is in a hurry,
processing it intelligently,
and then deciding,
OK, they're in a hurry,
I'm not, I'll let them in?
Or are they just following
some kind of social script?
Well, she had the person go
out and ask it in another way.
They would say, excuse me,
can I get in front of you?
Can I get in front
of you because I
have five pages to Xerox?
So now they're giving
a reason but it's
adding no more information.
So mathematically speaking,
or in terms of information
content, it's just like the
first way, where you just say,
can I get in front of you
without giving a reason?
So you should get
60% compliance.
But if people are automatically
following a script
and they'll let someone
in because the script says
if they give a
reason, let them in,
then you'll have 90% compliance.
And sure enough, they had
actually 93% compliance.
All you had to say is, because
I have five pages to Xerox,
rather than not say anything.
So this is an example
of people not realizing
that they're following a
script in a social interaction.
SPEAKER: So there's a
pro tip that you all
can walk away with if you want
to get in front of people.
LEONARD MLODINOW: I
find that's very useful.
SPEAKER: Because it's sunny.
LEONARD MLODINOW: [INAUDIBLE]
for a good reason,
we don't have to.
Just say "because."
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So with respect to generating
new ideas and so on,
you talked about
concept neurons.
What are those?
LEONARD MLODINOW: So that
has to do with the way
you store information
in your brain.
And around 2005, there are some
very interesting experiments
done with people who
had electrodes implanted
because they had intractable
epilepsy, so they had
to take readings
of the brain to see
what kind of surgical
procedure to do.
And these neuroscientists
piggybacked on those people
and did experiments on them, and
they would show them pictures
or tell them names.
And they would see what it
stimulated within the brain.
And they found that the neural
patterns for certain concepts--
or for concepts, period--
are very sparse in the brain.
It's not distributed over
millions and millions
of neurons, but there are very
specific neurons that respond
to very specific concepts.
And they respond not
just to the stimulus of--
let's say it's a person-- of the
person's face or their image.
But the same neuron would--
that's why they're called
concept neurons-- would
respond to the very
idea of that person.
So Halle Berry was one.
You could see Halle Berry
straight on, they would fire.
From the side, they would fire.
Dressed up in some
weird superhero outfit,
it would fire.
Just her name written
out, it would fire.
So that's why they named
them concept neurons.
They found that
concepts are represented
sparsely by different sets
of neurons in the brain.
And why that's
important is, when
we make associations to get
imaginative and creative ideas,
it's when different
networks of concept neurons
interact with each
other, and you get
combined to form a new concept.
SPEAKER: OK, that makes
sense in how it relates
to elasticity and so on.
Also, later on in the
book, you talk a little bit
how sentences are like puzzles.
How are sentences like puzzles?
LEONARD MLODINOW: Well,
when you hear language,
you're hearing a
string of words.
But each word can have
many different meanings
depending on the context.
So when you are
decoding what I say,
your brain is not
translating giving you
the idea of what each word means
as I go through the sentence.
It's actually waiting for
the sentence to get finished.
Or if it's a long
sentence, somewhere
along the way when it
has the right context,
it's doing a calculation
to figure out
for each word which of
its possible meanings
is the correct meaning.
So let's see if I get
this sentence right.
I have one in the book.
It said, the
cooking teacher said
the children made good snacks.
OK?
So that intro
line, you guys know
what I'm going to say next.
The other sentence
is, the cannibal said
the children made good snacks.
So if I hadn't given
you that intro, when
you heard the sentence
the cooking teacher said
the children made good snacks,
as your mind goes along,
the word made came along, it
would interpret it one way.
And if I said "the cannibal," it
would interpret it another way.
So every sentence like
that is a puzzle where
you have a number of words
that have some order.
And each word can have
different possible meanings.
And your brain has
to figure out what
set of meanings for these
words did you put together
to make that sentence.
And should I let you
ask another question,
or should I tell [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER: Oh, go ahead.
No, just--
LEONARD MLODINOW:
So, the reason that's
important is two language
researchers were looking
at what happens when
people have strokes
on the right side of the brain.
And people had
traditionally thought
that the left side of
the brain is important.
This is back through the
1950s and the early '60s.
And the right side, they would
say, it's just a throwaway.
You don't really need it.
It's just there.
I don't know what
they were thinking,
but basically that's
what they said.
And Roger Sperry, who
you may have heard of,
thought that that
would be ridiculous.
And he wanted to know what
the real difference was
between them.
And he realized
that by observing
people with strokes or other
brain damage [INAUDIBLE] other,
it wasn't controlled
enough to really tell.
He started cutting through the
corpus callosum of the animals
to separate the right
and the left brain.
And then he designed
experiments that
would address just
the right side or just
the left side of the brain.
And you can do that
because your senses also
go through the right.
[INAUDIBLE] so you can
present either auditory
signals or visual signals
to one side or the other,
and then you can
make tests to see,
if I teach the right side
of the brain something,
does the left side know it?
And he found that
they're basically
two independent information
processors, which
was very controversial
because you might imagine,
if you believe in
the soul, does that
mean you're two
souls or two people?
Or what does that mean?
But he ended up getting
a Nobel Prize for it.
And it didn't have quite
the impact that maybe it
should have through the years.
And people still were
kind of tending to dismiss
the right side of the brain.
And the left side is the one
that's known for language.
But these two researchers,
Kounios and Beeman,
were looking at the
deficits that people
had who had right side strokes,
and they were very interesting.
They had trouble
understanding metaphors,
and they had trouble
understanding jokes.
You would tell them
a joke, and they
wouldn't think it was funny.
Which usually if I tell
a joke, people think--
some fraction of the time.
If not, they have brain damage.
So think about that when you
choose whether or not to laugh.
So what they were
saying was, OK, well,
how does this relate--
if language is like a
puzzle, what does this mean?
And they eventually, through
a lot of experimentation
and thought, they
came to the conclusion
that when you hear a sentence
or when you see a puzzle,
or when you're at work
and you run into a problem
you have to solve, your
brain starts throwing out
ideas, associations as to how
we might approach it or solve
the problem.
And these are all being first
done on a subconscious level,
and not all of them
enter your consciousness.
Then there are various
filter circuits in your brain
that work together
to determine what
reaches your consciousness.
This is also the same
way that you have
inhibition of your behavior.
So if you walk by the
cafeteria and you're hungry
and you see a French
fry, your brain
is giving you the idea
to grab the French fry.
And your brain is also
censoring that idea,
because it's probably
not a good idea
to walk by and grab food from
other people's tables, right?
And in the book, I
tell a story about--
my dad had a stroke in
that part of his brain,
and he would grab
the French fry.
He would get the idea
and he would do it.
Well, that's bad because
we need these filters.
We need them to keep us
from doing stuff like that,
or if you're on
the second floor,
don't just jump out the
window, take the stairs.
And you don't want crazy
ideas when you're trying
to solve a problem either.
Or you get too many crazy
ideas, and you get nowhere.
On the other hand,
sometimes the crazy idea
is the one that
solves the problem.
And if your brain
is too conventional
and filters out all
those ideas, then you're
not going to solve the problem.
You're never going to
have a creative thought.
You're never going to innovate.
So it's all a balance.
And the idea in
elastic thinking is
how to tune this
balance for yourself.
So what Kounios
and Beeman realized
was that the right
side of your brain,
a certain structure on the
right side of your brain,
is producing these
more odd ideas.
And your left side of the
brain is producing the more
conventional ideas.
And then these different
structures in your brain
are choosing what to bring
to your consciousness.
And so a metaphor is based on
an odd interpretation of a word.
You are the light
of my life-- well,
I don't really mean that I can't
see unless you're in the room.
Or if you tell a
joke, it usually
does not depend on the literal
meaning of what's going on.
It depends upon
making some jumps.
So your right side of your brain
is understanding and proposing
these ideas, and your left side
the more conventional ones.
So the people who have the
brain damage on the right side
were not getting
these more, they
call them, remote associations--
only the more usual
associations, so they couldn't
understand jokes and metaphors.
But they realized that this is
part of a much broader theme,
which is that your
ideas in general
come that way, when you're
solving any puzzle in life,
not just the sentence
and the language.
Your right side of
your brain is proposing
the more odd solutions
or ideas or thoughts,
and the left side the
more conventional ones.
And your filters and your
different brain structures
are sorting through them.
SPEAKER: Yeah, related
to the word associations,
you brought up this instance
of these researchers who
had compound remote
association problems, which
they didn't quite
abbreviate like that, right?
LEONARD MLODINOW: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: Compound remote
association problems.
LEONARD MLODINOW:
They didn't want--
I mean, a lot of scientific
papers have that in them,
but no scientist wants to
actually use that word,
so they called them CRAs.
SPEAKER: Probably a wise move.
I think one example you gave
was pine, crab, and sauce
was one of the examples.
LEONARD MLODINOW: OK.
So here's the puzzle.
There's another word that
goes with each of those.
So if think of
cone, for instance,
it's the wrong one-- because
pine cone, but not sauce cone.
So it's pine, crab, and sauce.
That's one of their puzzles.
So there's two ways
to solve that puzzle,
just like there's
two ways of thinking.
You could analytically
start running
through words in your mind.
You may have some heuristic
about what kind of words
to run through.
Or you may start
with one of them,
like pine, and do
those words, and then
check each one
with the next word,
and then check that
with the next word.
Or you sit there and you go,
ah, and then it comes to you.
That's called insight.
They call it insight.
So what they were studying
was the different ways
that our brain works doing
one versus the other.
And one of the ways
that they could
tell what parts of your
brain are doing what is they
would image your brain
while you were doing that.
And sometimes they
would use something
called transcranial
stimulation, which
disrupts part of your
brain, so you can actually
electronically disrupt certain
structures in your brain.
And suddenly people are solving
these problems a lot better
than they were.
In one case, there was a
very experienced meditator
who was so good at
focus that he couldn't
solve any of these problems,
and he was kind of embarrassed.
And then he-- this is
a very important lesson
in the book-- he was able to see
that and change his thinking,
change his approach, relax,
and let his filters go away
and open up his mind.
And then he did [INAUDIBLE]
better than other people
generally did.
And these researchers
said, in all the years
of presenting these
problems, no one ever
had a switch like that.
So it's possible to take charge
of your brain and the way
you think.
And to throw in one more
random comment on that,
it's very interesting that they
could see in their subjects
brains through the--
they had to use
both, FMRI and EEG--
they could tell about
five or six seconds
before the subject even
solved the problem,
and even before they knew
what the problem was,
which way they would
do it-- whether it
was analytic or elastic.
And the subjects didn't
realize that they
had predetermined in their brain
what they were going to do.
But they were in one
mindset or another.
So they were either in
an analytical mindset
or an elastic mindset.
By reading their brains,
the experimenters
could tell which one it was.
And when they asked
them afterwards,
how did you solve
the problem, they
were right about
whether it was just
letting the thing come to you
or the analytical thinking.
Has anyone, by the way,
solved-- so it was--
the words were--
I don't want to
say-- crab, pine--
SPEAKER: To be clear, you
have to come up with one word
that pairs with each
of these other words.
LEONARD MLODINOW: Could
be before or after.
So pine, crab, and sauce.
AUDIENCE: Apple.
LEONARD MLODINOW:
Apple, there you go.
And did you get that by
logically reasoning it out,
or did it just come to you?
AUDIENCE: It just came to me.
LEONARD MLODINOW: OK.
Well, that's a
good way to get it.
So I talk a lot in
the book about ways
that you can help that.
And I think that
Google having a gym
here is a great thing
because that's one way.
You know, when you're thinking
in a very focused matter,
that's good to do if
you analyze the problem.
Then you want to let that go
and start thinking about it,
get on the treadmill, do
something that really takes you
away and doesn't let you
think about your grocery list
or what you have to do
at home or that problem,
and then things
will come to you.
Or taking the nap-- you
have little nap rooms,
that's a great thing.
They understand this here.
SPEAKER: I like how you do that.
You talk about, I guess, these
different modes of thinking
and how they can apply
to different situations.
And I think even in
the book you talk
about how you take advantage
of that during the day.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
LEONARD MLODINOW:
Well, one thing
is that your filters tend to
relax when you are exhausted,
or mentally exhausted.
So you might be a morning
person or an evening person.
But whatever it is,
one of the best times
if you need to find
creative solutions
is to do it when your analytic
mind just can't do any more.
So they do experiments
where they'd
have people solve these really
boring analytic thinking
problems, little arithmetic
problems or puzzles.
And afterwards, they'd
give them a problem that
requires some
creativity, and they'd
do better than the
people who were relaxed
and just go in to attack
the problem that way.
So that's one thing you can do.
I mean, another thing
is to realize that--
well, it's to realize that
it's good to stop and just take
a break.
And when you're taking a break
or you're laying on the couch
staring at the ceiling, you're
not necessarily goofing off.
You're legitimately
letting your mind work.
So you can legitimately be
working and consider yourself
at work when you're
laying down and you're
staring at the ceiling.
That's good to know.
And I found this great story
about Leonardo da Vinci.
He had his patrons who
would see him take a break.
And they would go, I'm
paying you all this money.
I want you to keep working.
And he argued with them, no.
When I take a break,
that is working.
So that's good-- you know, if
your supervisor doesn't know
that, just--
hey, [INAUDIBLE]
working for you now.
SPEAKER: And remember to use
"because," just like earlier.
LEONARD MLODINOW:
Use "because," right.
I'm laying on the couch because
I need to solve this problem,
not because I'm taking a nap.
SPEAKER: So I'm going to
keep asking questions.
But if any of you have
questions related to elasticity
or maybe how to
activate it and so on,
feel free to line up
at the mic, and we'll
start to mix those
in as time goes on.
And if not, you'll just get
to hear my prepared questions
the whole time, and put
all the pressure on me.
LEONARD MLODINOW: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: Yeah.
LEONARD MLODINOW: Pressure
is bad for elastic thinking.
SPEAKER: Well, fortunately
I have them written down,
so we've already
activated that part.
In the book, you also
mention your collaboration
with the late Stephen Hawking.
What did he teach you
about elastic thinking?
LEONARD MLODINOW: Well,
he taught many things.
And I think one of the
most unusual things
was because of the
way he communicated,
we had to interact in
a very unusual manner.
So to compose his
sentences, first he would--
when I first started
working with him,
he would use his thumb
to click a mouse,
and later he had a motion
sensor on his glasses
that would read when
his cheek twitched.
And that would be
like a mouse click.
And on his computer screen,
a cursor was flying around.
And there would be
rows of letters.
So first row, second row--
so he'd capture, let's say,
the second row.
Then it would start
moving across each letter.
He'd capture a letter.
Once he had a letter, it
gave him a choice of words.
Or he could do a second
letter, and then he
gets a choice of words with
those two letters, et cetera.
And it was about
six words a minute
that he could do that way.
So we were working together
even closer than this,
but there would
be no table there.
And he would be typing
out his sentences.
and at first, I'm zoning out.
I'm going, oh wow, OK, I'm--
I don't know, I'm daydreaming.
But then I actually realized--
I very soon realized that I
could see on his screen what
he's writing.
It would show.
And at the end, he
would click something
and the computer voice
would pronounce it.
But you could watch him
composing his sentences,
and I would look
over his shoulder
and I would start thinking
about what he was saying.
So it's really interesting.
And sometimes if I knew
what he was saying,
I would say, oh, you're
saying, blah blah blah.
But sometimes I
would just let it
go, even though I
knew what it was,
because I could think about it.
So as we're talking, I'm
not thinking very much.
It's probably pretty automatic.
When you say something--
it's a fixed action pattern.
You say something that
triggers my brain to something
in the book, and I'm just
reading the book to you guys.
But in most conversations
it's pretty immediate.
You don't talk to somebody,
and then you're not
going to wait four minutes--
if your friend's waiting
four minutes for you
to say something--
I mean, if you're stoned
maybe, but not generally.
So this was different.
Our Conversations, then,
at least from my side,
were very different
because I could
think more deeply about
what we were talking about.
I also had the time to figure
out what he was talking about
because his mind
could go pretty fast.
But it's a very important
thing because quite often we
don't think deeply enough,
or you take the first answer
that you get at
something, and that's
not the creative answer--
that's, let's say,
it gets to their answer
but not the best answer.
And if you would
only stop and say,
no, I want something better and
not just accept that answer,
then you would get better ideas.
And there's a good
experiment in the book
that they talk about
with chess players.
And they give-- so
who here plays chess?
Is this a chess-playing crowd?
Well, you know they these
magazines or websites
that give you chess puzzles.
It's a board position
and they say,
how do you force a checkmate
in three moves or five moves?
So they give you
the board position,
and your problem is to
figure out how you--
given you're white, let's
say, and it's your move,
force your opponent
into a checkmate
in a given number of moves.
So they designed
a nice situation
where there was
an easy solution.
It took five moves.
And there was a very clever
solution that took three moves.
So that's considered better.
And they gave this to a lot
of different chess players
to solve, and they
correlated how good
the chess player was according
to their master points--
so that's a rating system
they have in chess--
to whether they could
solve this problem.
And then to some
of the people, they
would show the easy
solution first.
No, I'm sorry.
Some people would be given the
board where the easy solution
was not present.
And others would be given
the board, the problem,
where an easy and a hard
one were both present.
And what they found was
that they were really
good, the experts, at
solving the hard problem
when the easy--
would start getting
the hard solution
when the easy one wasn't there.
But when the easy one was
there and they of course
would immediately answer
it, they were a lot worse.
They would not
find the hard one.
And they did some
statistical correlations
and found that it was
like the equivalent,
I think, to 300 master
points or something.
So I mean, that's a huge
difference in chess.
And I forgot-- I said
it in the book-- it's
like an IQ difference
between 90 and 120,
or something like that.
I mean, really knowing
the easy answer
made people a lot dumber
at finding the more
creative answer.
So just something
to think about.
I really like that
aspect of the book
that you had various
problems there.
We talked about one of them
with the crab, the pine,
and the sauce.
We talked about the chess one.
You also have various
little quizzes
where you can measure how open
you are to new experiences,
and there are other
quizzes like that.
I like that aspect
of it a lot, that you
have these various
interactive things.
I think we have a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you hear me?
SPEAKER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
I have a question about how
to reward elastic thinking,
because humans are kind
of a reward-driven animal.
But most of our reward
system is trying
to be really analytical-- so
they track your performance
over time, you can
have a metric about it,
and that's how you can
get a reward for it,
because the metric
shows that you did well.
But for creativity
or elasticity,
it doesn't seem there's--
at least I don't know a good way
of saying, oh, you did good in,
and therefore I can reward you
and hope that you'll continue
to do more elastic thinking.
LEONARD MLODINOW:
That's a great question,
and we could do a
whole hour on that.
And as you can tell, my
mouth tends to keep going.
But-- so there are two kinds of
rewards that people who study
this talk about--
extrinsic rewards and
intrinsic rewards.
So your brain has
a reward system
that I talk about in the
book that rewards you
when you do certain things.
And those are, by definition,
the things you like.
I don't see, it does certain
things you like to do,
but you like to do them
because it's rewarding you
and kind of works together.
And then there's money
and money-related things--
you know, gifts or--
I don't want to say
praise because praise
is kind of in between.
But what psychologists
have found
is that the extrinsic
rewards are not really good.
They can be quite
counterproductive.
Now, if they tell you
you have to finish
writing this code
by Monday and it's
really important to the company,
and we'll give you 10 grand
if you do it, you'll
probably do it.
So for short term, very
well-defined things, you know,
it tends to work.
People, their conscious mind
takes over, and they do it.
More long term and
less define things
like, are you, for
instance, going
to be a better employee if
you're rewarded monetarily,
that doesn't really follow.
And the more creative
the task you're doing
is the less important or
even the more negative
the monetary reward is.
I actually quote Dostoevsky
who wasn't a psychologist,
but he was complaining about
this hellish assignment
he had to write this novel.
And I forgot what novel it
was, but what a torture it was.
And when you hear
that, you don't
realize that he wrote
on spec like that, where
someone says write about--
you know.
And it wasn't at all.
It was just to write a novel.
The assignment was
just to write a novel.
But he was being paid--
he had a contract
to write a novel.
And for him, that totally
killed his creativity.
And so that's maybe
an extreme example,
but that's the tendency
of what happens.
Researchers have found that when
you pay people and give them
this extrinsic motivation,
it tends to interfere
with their creativity.
But the intrinsic
motivation, which
comes from you, which
is Google saying to you,
what do you like?
Let's assign you to do that.
Let's put you in the
area that you like to do.
And if you later on want to
change, to be open to say,
oh, you want to move over
there and do that, that's
intrinsic motivation that
comes deeper within you
from within your own brain,
and that is very important
and very effective.
SPEAKER: I'm going to call back.
Just a moment ago you
mentioned somebody
potentially being stoned.
It came up in your book
as well, being stoned.
It's legal in this state.
How does being stoned
relate to elastic thinking?
LEONARD MLODINOW: That's the
cure for everything, duct tape.
So marijuana-- well, OK, alcohol
also and marijuana and certain
psychedelic drugs--
I always have trouble
pronouncing, ayahuasca,
they act on those filters
I was talking about.
So that's just a chemical way
of loosening those filters
and allowing more creative
ideas to go through.
Now, I should say,
which I do in the book,
that they all have
their own downsides.
I don't just mean
you get drunk and you
could walk through a window.
I mean more objectively
that marijuana
has other effects on your
brain, your short-term memory,
how to keep things in
your working memory.
I don't know if you've ever
had that experience where
you're stoned and you
forget what you were saying.
I mean, I get that even
when I'm not stoned.
But more often when I am, I
guess-- not that I ever am.
If you're doing this outside
of California, never do it.
So that can impede--
also for a lot of things, you
need that executive function
to guide your thinking.
And so thoughts are coming,
but there's no guidance.
And so you're
detached from reality.
And so there are
these different aids
that you might try that many
artists and musicians swear by.
They have their plus signs
and their minus signs,
and you have to use
them intelligently
if you're using them
for that purpose.
If you're not, use
them any way you want.
SPEAKER: Yeah, using
drinking to help
the elastic thinking
reminds me of that quote
from that character
in "Game of Thrones."
That's what I do--
I drink and I know things.
And it seems--
LEONARD MLODINOW: There you go.
Anyway, do we have
another question?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious kind of
the difference between the--
I've heard it talked about as
the subconscious background
processing thinking
versus elastic thinking.
Like, you read a riddle
right before you go to bed.
And then you wake up and you
either dream about the answer,
or just the answer hit
you out of nowhere.
Or is this the same thing
as the shower epiphany
that a lot of people have?
LEONARD MLODINOW: Right.
They're all related--
when you have a problem
that you set up
analytically in your head.
But the answer is not the
product of an algorithm.
The answer is,
let's say, changing
the way you solved a
problem, for instance--
changing your assumptions,
or changing the paradigm.
It's more like you
guys are started
to use these neural
nets, which I
think is the key to success
in computer science.
And I wrote a paper
in the '80s about it.
So that's elastic thinking.
The neural nets--
with the neural nets,
though, you don't know how
it got to the answer, right?
You set it up so
that the computer is
doing this crazy stuff
and it's learning.
And at the end,
you don't know what
algorithm it used in its
brain to get the answer.
And that's the same
thing with humans.
And so when you get these
ideas, it's from the bottom up.
It's your neural nets in your
brain doing some calculation,
giving you the answer.
It's not some algorithm
saying, do this then do this
and then do that.
So yes, that's really the
big difference, is that--
or one of the big differences--
is that analytical thinking
tends to be top down,
and elastic thinking
tends to be bottom
up calculation.
SPEAKER: I don't know,
talking about the neural nets
and so on, it's kind of
interesting because it
was mentioned that the season--
or the time that you wrote
for "The Next Generation,"
you all were exploring
some things around Data
and how much he
was thinking also.
And that kind of is a
similar idea, I suppose.
LEONARD MLODINOW: Yeah.
Because we had the very
naive concept of Data--
or Spock was half
of [INAUDIBLE],,
so it's kind of the
same role, where this is
totally logical and rational.
But in reality,
somebody who is total--
or a thing that is totally
rational or logical
is never going to
solve anything or do--
I mean, first of all
they won't even get
started because if something
is rational and logical,
it usually needs to be
told to do something
and then it can do that task.
But something that
is bottom up thinking
or has emotional
content, which is
why you have a reward
center in your brain
and you have emotions, is to get
you to realize that you should
even start doing something.
So in reality, if Data
was purely a computer,
it would sit there and
wait to be given a problem,
and then he would answer it.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
I think that plays in a little
bit to some of the other topics
you talk about-- when you
mentioned choice overload,
for example.
What is choice overload?
LEONARD MLODINOW: Well,
so in today's society,
we have a lot of
options for everything.
You go to the grocery store,
and there's 40 different kinds
of ketchup or cereal.
One researcher I talked
about did a survey, reported
how many of each different
products were in the grocery
store, and it was bad.
And these are the
kinds of things
that can exhaust your brain
and get you on these loops that
are not productive.
And what psychologists have
found was that there's--
I don't want to say two kinds
of people, because that's always
[INAUDIBLE].
But there's two ends of a
one-dimensional spectrum.
And one end, they
call them maximizers.
These are miserable people--
I'm often one of them--
who want to optimize
and maximize the utility
and economics of everything.
So when I'm presented with 40
different kinds of mayonnaise,
I will spend an hour
analyzing each one
and trying to figure
out which one is better
than the other one, even
though it really doesn't matter
or doesn't matter much.
At the other end
are the satisficers,
they call them,
who as soon as they
find the first one that works,
take that one and they go
along very happily.
So that's what I recommend.
Well, let's think
about that again.
Is that really the best answer?
SPEAKER: I find it
interesting when
you were talking about
the creative thinking
and you related
to schizophrenic--
schizotypic personality traits.
How are those two intertwined?
LEONARD MLODINOW: So--
people pronounce it
both schizotypies, or
schizo-tip-ees, is a trait that
is related to schizophrenia.
So again, if you
think of a spectrum,
there would be people
who are far to one
end are schizophrenic,
and then there
are people with
different traits,
different degrees of that.
And that has to do with how
attached you are to reality,
and do you have a tendency
toward odd and magical
thinking?
So based on what
I've said so far,
you can imagine
that this has to do
with some of the filters in your
brain and to getting new ideas.
So people who are near
the schizophrenic side
can often be extremely creative.
Well, it's not very
creative but extremely good
at idea generation
and generating
novel, divergent ideas.
They're not really often very
creative, because that also
takes some analytical thinking
to channel and figure out
what you need and put
everything together.
So this is an interesting trait
to look at, because in a way
it's a measure of your filters.
And when your
filters are too low,
then you're detached
from reality.
But if your filters
are too high,
then you're so conventional that
you'll never have a new idea.
And that still has
its place more so
than the other side in society.
But it's a very important
aspect of elastic thinking.
SPEAKER: Yeah, it struck
me as kind of tragic.
I mean, some people are
right on the border.
I think you referenced--
LEONARD MLODINOW: Nash.
SPEAKER: Yeah, John Nash.
LEONARD MLODINOW: He was
on the border for years
and was enough reality
based to do the work that
got him the Nobel Prize, and
then he went over the edge
and he schizophrenic for some
years, and then he recovered.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
We have another question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I'm
actually an improviser as well
as somebody here.
And so it seems to
me, in that role
I get my own way to practice
some of this creative thinking
that I wouldn't get
if I just did work.
Are there other ways that
you have seen that work
to help people get this more
creative aspect of themselves
or train their brain to
be more elastic thinking?
LEONARD MLODINOW: Yeah.
So I talk about different
things you can do.
One is meditation and often
meditation related exercises
that make you more mindful.
So one of important things
to be is mindful and how
are you attacking a problem.
And when you're
getting to a barrier
and when it's good to stop
and take another approach
and to be mindful of yourself
and to know what it is that you
do that can help do that.
Another thing is, it's
very important to overcome
the fear of failure.
I don't know how Google is
about that, but some companies,
if you screw up, they--
whatever, bad review
or your project
failed or you did
something that didn't work
and you get criticized
for it, and they
make you afraid to
fail, which is a very--
it's a creativity killer.
As a theoretical physicist,
I know that almost every idea
I have sucks.
And sometimes the
only question is,
does it take me five
minutes or 50 days
to figure out that it sucks?
And then you go
through a lot of those
and eventually you get
one that doesn't, and you
publish something.
But if you're afraid
to make that jump--
or even when I'm writing
it's the same way.
I write a lot of
stuff that's stupid.
And I just hope that I notice
that before I publish the book
and take it out and
somebody tells me.
But if I was afraid to write
something that was stupid,
I would never write anything
that was interesting either.
I would just write a textbook.
So I think that's another thing.
Work on your fear of failure.
And if you have a
problem, I think
it's very important to fail,
talk about when you fail,
think about when you fail, think
about when other people fail,
open up about it
and get used to it.
Like, when I learned
how to ski, I
realized soon that
the first thing
I would do when I
got to the ski slope
is fall over because I was
skiing really stiff because I
didn't want to fall over.
And I was skiing badly
because I was afraid to fall.
But if I fall immediately,
I get that over
with, oh, it's not so bad.
I'm going to fall today.
I'm not Going to
have a fall-free day.
And then I could really ski.
And it's the same
thing with failure.
So it's good to fail.
Get used to it,
embrace it, enjoy it.
The more you fail, the
more success you'll have.
Just keep doing it.
Or the more--
consistently speaking.
I'm not saying that
failure is a success.
So that's another
thing you can do.
Oh.
Argue with people.
Arguing is very good.
Talk to people who
totally disagree with you,
who are very different.
If you're a very
conventional eater,
go to the weirdest
restaurant you can.
Travel-- I mean, all these
things, they've shown,
have increased your
elastic thinking.
They've even shown-- it was
an interesting experiment.
They had people in a room, and
they had these paint chips.
And some were red, some were
green, and some were blue.
And they'd have 10
people in the room.
One of them was a confederate,
an associate of the researcher,
because if you're
ever in a experiment,
you'll know that it's
never what they tell you.
And everyone says, is
this green or blue.
And they say, blue, blue, blue.
And then this
confederate said, green.
The thing was obviously
blue, but he would say green.
That was the experiment.
So then they told
people, you're going
to be in an
unrelated experiment.
Well, if a psychologist
ever tells you that, no.
Just laugh in their face.
So the second experiment,
supposedly unrelated,
was they'd give you these
paint chips to categorize.
Now, they're all on the
spectrum between blue and green.
So there's a continuous
spectrum of frequency
between blue and green, and
they would give you these paint
chips and you had to say which
are blue and which are green.
Well, guess what.
Even though the
people who saw the guy
in that other
experiment, he called--
whatever I said, he called
the blue chip green--
and they thought that was
stupid, it was really blue--
when they are now
categorizing these chips,
it all depends on
where you draw the line
between green and blue.
Well, the ones who saw that guy
who said that green was blue
drew the line much
closer to blue--
I mean made the blue
section much bigger
than the ones who
weren't in that.
So even though this person's
ridiculous statement
didn't seem to
influence them, they
were influenced subtly
later on in their judgment.
So even when someone
says something
that you totally
disagree with and you go,
that's really stupid,
it can actually
have an effect on
your thinking--
but I mean a positive effect.
It can expand your thinking
and the kinds of possibilities
that you think about.
So yeah.
We'll have some more of
this raspberry juice.
SPEAKER: Now I have
that in my head.
LEONARD MLODINOW:
You're right, it's head.
SPEAKER: Well, we'll
wrap up with this.
You have various bits of wisdom
from your parents in the book.
I read something about
a worm and horseradish.
You'll have to read the book
to know more about that.
And from your mother, you
have the phrase, where
there's a will, there's a way.
How does this relate
to being elastic?
LEONARD MLODINOW:
Well, it has to do
with what I was
talking about failure
and about how sometimes the
best elastic thinking comes
from when you don't
accept what you see,
or when you don't accept that
you're not going to get there
and you just keep trying.
So the idea is that if you
broaden your perspective
and the amount that--
broaden the range of ideas that
you find that you'll consider
or that your brain
proposes to you,
you have a much greater
chance of solving a problem,
even though you think that
it can't possibly be solved.
SPEAKER: Well,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]